django tu as déjà vu des gens pareils et
mon père a monté des choix de course des
10 dont pourquoi tout le monde délire
sur toi et personne ne te dire que tu es
grossier m
c'est du snobisme
[Musique]
je ne sais pas je suis déjà venue en
france cinq ou six fois et maintenant on
dirait que les français on vraiment
envie de rien il ya plein de trucs
vulgaire chose mais comme je suis un
clown eux s'apprêtent de choses que tout
le monde fait remonter péter et faire
l'amour
et tout le monde se marre pendant tout
le spectacle quoi oui c'est super
moi aussi je me bats je prends vraiment
beaucoup de plaisir si je pouvais rester
plus longtemps
resterait encore un an et j'ai d'autres
engagements pour cette annonce à l
moscou au canada dans le monde entier
quoi oui sauf en amérique
partout sauf en amérique pourquoi je
sais pas les américains sont au rouge
est enfin prêt pour moi parle-moi de toi
c'est vrai que quand tu avais 20 berges
tu vendes et de l'herbe
oui j'étais paysagistes professionnels
un paysage mais pas de l'herbe à fumer
de l'herbe
je construisais des terrains de golf
d'ailleurs à detroit j'ai encore un
terrain de jeu et après c'est vrai que
tu as lu kerouac ferling et higgins
berck timothy leary tout à fait et après
tu as décidé de venir un marginal qui
jamais arrêté de chercher quelque chose
dans ma vie
la vie est importante en valeur dans les
années 60 quand je sens bien que si des
gens vendent tu appris de l'un s'il
était jamais redescendu en quoi c'est ça
un site marianne
e
samson mon vieux alors tu as travaillé
comme paysagiste a pris de la cites a
fumé de l'armée puis tu t'es aperçu que
ce n'était pas un bon style de vie quoi
tu t'es pas heureux j'avais plein
d'argent une grosse voiture le foyer les
filles et j'étais souvent et ça c'est
pas vivre vivre je décidé que la seule
chose à faire c'était d'essayer d'aider
les gens comme il dit par le riz c'est
une sorte de thérapie terapeak est très
importante très simples ou très
important c'est vrai que tu as décidé de
devenir marginal après avoir lu un
bouquin open skies qui s'appelle fouet
et qu'est-ce qui pouvait raconter par
une telle influence sur toi je pense
qu'il racontait l'histoire d'un mec a
pris au piège une école ici affronter de
très nombreux livres qui sont la
conscience de soi sur la connaissance
rapports avec
[Musique]
c'est une chose qui m'a fait prendre
conscience et comment on ai dit moi même
comment prendre conscience se regarder
soi même klum sont un peu un reflet à
reflets des gens beaucoup de gens disent
que les clowns sont tristes mais s'ils
ont cette impression tenace collecte lui
montre aux gens de quoi ils ont l'air et
les gens sont tristes
mais dis moi en général quand on lit des
gens comme je crie robineau krishnamurti
gurdjieff open skies on ne décide pas de
devenir toulouse on décide plutôt
d'aller en ashram newsletter feuillets
monsieur ben c'est la vraie guerre de
vivre dans la civilisation occidentale
reste fait partie de la civilisation
orientale quatrième chemin
c'est une manière de mieux appréhender
la civilisation occidentale genre humain
les affaires les clous de fonds se sont
déjà ils n'ont pas besoin d'avoir un
héros les intervieweurs clown des clowns
plaine des bouchers et qunu il ya un
coup dans chacun de nous épater l'une de
tout le monde dans cette tâche pour
avoir d'autres témoins c'est pas moi qui
fait les frais
il est pas très content le mec là je
vais essayer avec la bouteille qu'est ce
que tu dirais à quelqu'un qui va t'en
chaude les smartphones qui nourrit pas
je le fais à peu près difficile de venir
à mon spectacle de paris il a vu
d'alcool de 5h30 un bien beau spectacle
fait tellement de trucs chaque soir
qu'il ya peut-être des choses que le
champ d'un parent il ya toujours quelque
chose qui les aident général bord à la
sortie s'il allait à mon spectacle à la
partie importante du show c'est quand
c'est terminé
nous appliquons du g20 autre chose je
n'étais pas la sortie bennabi tueur je
suis à la sortie de tous les soirs quand
les gens sortent je regarde le visage
qui au jour pendant mon spectacle il ya
une chose que vous devez pouvoir vous
donner
je voudrais que vous soyez à ma place
comme ça on pourriez voir au visage
quand je regarde voilà le public les
gens sont comme ça et c'est un moment
d'espoir moment de rigolade de
relaxation même si c'est grossier même
si c'est classe et sexy si tu les feras
pain oui je n'ai pas possible j'adore ça
leur balance des oeufs sur la gueule
si vous venez voir mettez un appel si
vous êtes au premier rang il préfère la
france tu reviens toujours en france
j'aimerais bien toujours j'adore la
france est un pays super en ce moment je
suis déjà venu mais en ce moment les
gens vraiment envie de rien
je sais pas c'est parce qu'ils ont plus
personne pour les faire marrer
maintenant en plus les élections
présidentielles en fils c'est une bonne
occasion de rigoler la comédie à la
politique proche bien des points qu'elle
subirait aux français avant qu'ils
aillent voter pour le prochain président
je leur dirais tu as déjà vu les jambes
pareil quand je regarde de plus près ils
ont un autre ajoute m c'est le gardien
chose chansons que j'ai écrites pour les
sources classiques mais vu différemment
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu